that's nonsense and it's throttling uh
recovery and it's throttling economic
activity question 11 sir
thank you mr speaker union connectivity
review recommended a multi-modal review
of the north wales transport corridor
including the a55 in the north wales
mainland we are considering this and the
other recommendations in the review
rob robert
thank you mr speaker after we received
the
union connectivity review five months
later than scheduled give my right oral
friend indicate when the recommendations
of the review will be implemented and
will he throw the weight of his office
behind the new station in greenfield
which is already being established as
vital to connectivity in the region
thank you
the only member raises a a good point we
haven't got a precise date as yet other
than to say that there is some imminence
to it and i would ask him actually also
to bear in mind that thanks to
interventions and recommendations by the
treasury there are other funding models
available too so don't overlook the work
that he can do with his local authority
around things like the leveling up
finding the shared prosperity fund in
the future
order before we come to prime minister's
questions
i would like to point out the british
sign language interpretation proceedings
is available to watch on the parliament
live tv bsl interpretation will also be
available for the prime minister's
statement for loom pmq's
i now call
dr jamie wallace
mr speaker
[Music]
mr speaker i start by wishing you and
all members a happy new year
thanks to the heroic efforts of our
vaccination program and people coming
forward up and down the country we
managed to ensure that families could
still celebrate christmas with over 34
million people now boosted and i want to
take opportunity to say that anybody who
has not yet done so should come forward
and get boosted now
mr speaker this morning i had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today dr jeb
thank you mr speaker uh sadiq khan's tfl
in tatters and the welsh labour
nationalist coalition in cardiff bay an
unfunded devolved disaster
does the prime minister agree with me
that the great british public don't need
to look back at the last uk labour
government to see what this opposition's
answer to all our problems is which is
to bang at the doors of the treasury
demanding that the taxpayer bail them
out of their own ineptitude and
incompetence
[Applause]
mr speaker it's not just labour's record
in london or in wales every labour
government in history since the second
world war has left office with
unemployment higher than when they came
in and that's because only conservatives
can be trusted to deliver on the economy
and on people's on the people's
priorities and that is why mr speaker
this country now thanks to the policies
we've pursued has the fastest economic
growth in the g7
it now comes to the deputy leader of the
opposition angela
thank you mr speaker and a happy new
year to you and the rest of the house
mr speaker over the christmas break the
world lost a giant in the fight of
equality and human rights the great
desmond tutu
and i would like to offer my condolences
to his family and to the people of south
africa and i'd also like to thank
all of those key workers who have kept
our essential services running over the
festive period
particularly all those staff and
volunteers working at vaccination sites
and our amazing nhs staff working
incredibly hard with incredibly
stretched circumstances but i know we're
going to come on to that after pmq's
with the prime minister and i'd also
like to thank the formidable sue gray
who i know has been busier than sansa
over the festive period
mr speaker
in october
in october
the prime minister said
that fears about inflation were
unfounded
but working people
across the country are starting the new
year facing rising bills and ballooning
prices so how did he get it so wrong
yeah
uh well mr speaker uh what the
government has been i of course i said
no such thing because inflation is
always something uh that we that we have
to be uh that we have to be careful uh
about but what we are doing mr speaker
is making is making sure
making sure that we protect the people
of this country throughout what is
unquestionably going to be a difficult
period and that's why
we are ensuring that we've lifted the
living wage uh by record sums mr speaker
we make sure people have
cold weather payments uh making sure
that they have the uh the warm homes
discount all the other protections the
500 million pound fund that we've put in
uh to help local councils uh look after
people uh through all will be a
difficult period but the most important
thing we can do to look after people
during this very difficult time mr
speaker is to ensure that we take the
balanced and proportionate approach
that we are
to ensure that we're able to keep our
country and our society going mr speaker
and uh that is exactly what we are doing
and that is why we double down on the
booster program and that is why we are
sticking with plan b mr speaker that's
the right approach for the country
angela rainer mr speaker inflation is
about to hit six percent
that's the highest rate since the early
nineties when the conservatives have
been in power for over a decade mad in
their sleeves with a divided party a
prime minister losing the support of his
backbenchers and governing shambolically
and a labour party mr speaker who is
ready to take over and provide the
britain with a better future
familiar
mr speaker
the prime minister promised wage risers
would offset inflation they haven't and
they won't
millions of british workers now face a
further pay cut and his chancellor is
handing them a tax hike
what will the prime minister do to get a
grip
[Applause]
mr speaker i i know that she uh it's
great to be here with the the right
honourable lady of the shadow secretary
of state for the future of work we know
the future of the job that she has in
mind uh but
i wish i wish i wish i wish i will i
wish i will
but what we are focused on what we are
focused on mr speaker
is delivering jobs for the british
people
and it is a quite extraordinary thing uh
that there are now record numbers of
people in work mr speaker
420 000 more than there were before the
pandemic began uh mr speaker uh we have
youth unemployment at a record low mr
speaker and never let it be forgotten uh
that when omitron when omicron hit this
country mr speaker what was their
instinctive response
they said yep that's right mr speaker
they said they needed a road map that we
needed a road map to lock down if we
listened to them we wouldn't have
anybody working at all mr speaker
absolutely
mr speaker i've heard on the grapevine
there might be a vacancy for prime
minister soon so maybe i should have
aspirations
the prime minister presents it's not his
fault
he blames the global forces he blames
the market mr speaker we're an
aspirational party maybe the prime
minister needs to be more aspirational
for this country
[Music]
but mr speaker the prime minister has
made political choices that has led us
into this place his government has
failed to invest in long-term energy
security his government decided to let
gas storages collapse his government let
the energy market run out of control
27 energy companies have gone bust in
the last year and now household bills
are going through the roof or as the
money-saving expert martin lewis put it
there will be a seismic hit on energy
bills
can't the prime minister see what's
happening yet again working families are
picking up the tab for his incompetence
[Applause]
mr speaker she talks he talks about
energy i think the house will agree
she's got a lot more energy in the
current leader
of the opposition and i i i welcome her
uh her point because actually what the
government is doing is supporting people
throughout the uh the pandemic uh
2.2 million people supported with the
warm homes discount mr speaker worth 140
pounds per week which we introduced
pensioners supported with a 300 pounds
winter fuel payments uh mr speaker cold
cold weather payments worth 25 pounds a
week for four million people up and down
the country was because that is what we
are that is what we are doing mr speaker
and that is on top of everything we're
doing to support uh people on low
incomes cutting uh taxes for the those
on universal credit increasing
increasing the living wage a thousand
pounds more for everybody on the living
wage at record times and mr speaker let
me just remind the house of the
fundamental difference between that
party and this government they they
would have they would have kept us in
lockdown in july mr speaker and when
overcrowd when omicron hit they were
calling for further restrictions we've
been that's right mr speaker we've been
able to keep this country moving and
keep the economy growing and keep the
money coming into people's pockets mr
speaker
mr speaker i'll tell you what this prime
minister is doing is increasing taxes to
the hard-working people of this country
that's what he's doing that's what he
didn't promise in his manifesto but
that's what he's doing to the people and
i quote mr speaker the poorest household
spend three times more on their income
on household energy bills and the
richest household spend v80 on energy
bills makes gas and electricity more
expensive not my words mr speaker but
the words of the prime minister himself
when energy bills are going to be hiked
again in april any decent government
would find a way to help british
families even the tory back benches have
finally accepted labour's call to cut
v80 on energy bills so will he finally
stand up to his chancellor and do the
same
mr speaker let me remind because he
wasn't obviously listening to the
previous answer uh let me let me remind
her the warm homes discount already 2.2
million people supported the tune of 140
pounds a week
pensioners supported uh with 300 pounds
through the winter fuel payment uh the
the the cold weather payments for four
million people and she now they now have
the effrontery mr speaker
having campaigned and she did too i
think didn't she
oh yes she campaigned to remain in the
eu oh yes oh yes
they now have the bare-faced chief
to come to this country to this to this
house of commons and say that they want
to cut the 80 on fuel when everybody
knows and he did too mr speaker
everybody knows full well it would be
absolutely impossible if they were to do
what labor would do and go back into the
eu remain aligned with the eu single
market that is the objective of the
labour party they can't be trusted on
brexit mr speaker and they can't be
trusted on the economy
so prime minister how's it going are you
okay
the prime minister and his chancellor
have presided over economic
mismanagement
low growth
and neglect of our public services and
their resolution to fix this whacking
more taxes on working people combine the
tax rise with soaring energy prices and
the average family faces a hit of a
1200 pound
this is an iceberg mr speaker right
ahead
so will he finally stop and change call
or order order
we started the new year not in the way
we left the last one you did give me an
assurance we're going to try and calm
down so if we can it will be helpful
angela right now
mr speaker
one thousand two hundred pound hit right
away
so will he finally stop and change
course or will he plow on towards what
will be a disaster for thousands of
families
mr speaker as a direct result of what
we've already done on universal credit a
single mother with two kids is 1200
pounds uh better off mr speaker as a
result of what we've done with the
living wage mr speaker introduced by
this conservative government they never
let it be never let it be forgotten uh
everybody on the living wage has seen
another thousand pounds uh in their
income every year mr speaker but but
that's not the point the fundament that
we will continue to look after people
throughout the pandemic but the
fundamental point is that because of the
steps the government has taken because
of the tough decisions we've taken
because of the balanced and the
proportionate approach that we've taken
to kovid we've been able to keep this
country open keep our economy moving
more open than any other comparable
economy in europe and they know it mr
speaker and they opposed it every step
of the way and that's why people are
seeing increases in employment and
increases in their pay package as well
[Applause]
mr speaker this prime minister always
gives with one hand and takes away with
the other under this prime minister the
country is worse off prices for everyday
gods are soaring out of control
hard earned savings will be hit and the
wages of working people won't go as far
inflation isn't an economic
theory it has serious consequences for
people's lives we need serious solutions
mr speaker to stop the people
falling into poverty or debt
instead mr speaker we have this prime
minister and his incompetent leadership
and every time we are faced with a
challenge he denies there's a problem he
tries to laugh it off he looks for
someone else to blame
so can i suggest to the prime minister
it's not about brushing your hair it's
about brushing up on your act
does he accept his incompetence it's
taking our country backwards and costing
our country dear
no mr speaker what i what i tell the
house to tell the country is that labour
incompetence has ruined this country
time and time again
and there has never been a labor
government that has left office with
unemployment lower than when they came
in and what is her answer mr speaker to
the energy crisis it is to nationalize
our energy it was in fact labor's
failure to invest in uh supply over over
a decade or more uh that reduced our
ability uh to have uh cheaper cleaner
energy mr speaker we are rectifying that
we're taking the tough decisions that
this country needs for the long term and
it's because we've taken those tough
decisions mr speaker because we've taken
the balanced and proportionate approach
that we have that they opposed every
step of the way that we have youth
unemployment and a record low we have
420 000 more people in jobs now than
there were before the pandemic began and
mr speaker we not only have the most
open uh society and economy in europe
but we also have the fastest economic
growth in the g7 uh completely contrary
to what she has just said speaking and
that is because of our stable balance a
proportionate approach and and when when
never let it be forgotten when omicron
when omicron presented itself what did
they go for they reached for the lever
of more restrictions they said locked
down mr speaker we said boosters they
comp from the sidelines we get on with
the job
[Applause]
you want more you won't get more at this
rate will you
mr penrose has been waiting patiently
why do you not want to hear him because
i do john penrose
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker the biggest factor
driving up our fuel bills and cost of
living is the skyrocketing international
price of gas which is currently dancing
to a tune set in moscow
will the prime minister agree with me
that labor's short-term proposals to
shift the burden from bill payers to
taxpayers won't address this fundamental
underlying problem at all that the
crisis demands structural form to the
energy price cap rather than just
resetting it later this year and energy
self-sufficiency to uncouple us from
russian gas as well
yes i thank my honorable friend and he
is completely right and that's why
this government is taking the tough
decision to invest in the long-term uh
future of our energy supply investing in
massively increasing our supply
renewables but nuclear as well uh mr
speaker and that is the right way
forward for this country and i think it
is absolutely um and it was labour of
course who completely failed to take
those decisions with the result that uh
nuclear in particular uh fell away uh
dramatically and it is absolutely
farcical that their their answer today
uh labour's answer today to the to the
energy uh price rises which which my
older friend correctly diagnoses is to
nationalize our energy yes it is is it
well maybe they changed their minds now
but it was and maybe maybe they've had a
second maybe they've had but their
answer was to nationalize our energy
sector and to send bills even higher and
that is not the way forward they did the
smp in blythe
thank you mr speaker can i wish you
colleagues and all staff uh a good new
year
mr speaker
over the
last few weeks
serious warnings have grown over the
tory cost of living crisis which will
hit the majority of families over the
coming months
new research from the resolution
foundation has found that on average
that families will be 1200 pounds worse
off from april as a result of tory cuts
tax hikes and soaring energy bills now
for members of the tory government
1200 pounds
might not seem very much
for the
for the foreign
secretary and it's just another
taxpayer-funded lunch in mayfair
for the prime minister
it's just a roll of fancy wallpaper for
these taxpayers funded flat
but for the vast majority of families
losing 1200 pounds a year will be
catastrophic
for some it will mean that they can't
afford to pay their rent and bills to
hate their homes or to put food on the
table so will the prime minister
apologize for leaving millions of
families worse off and will he commit to
an emergency financial package to
reverse history cost of living crisis
mr speaker i find that criticism hard to
take from the the humble crofter
[Applause]
but uh what we are doing uh with whom i
as i stressed with i have normally very
very good uh relations off the pitch uh
but uh what we are doing and what we are
doing is helping families up and down uh
the country uh tapering uh making sure
that uh a single mother with two kids uh
gets 1200 more on universal credit a
thousand pounds more uh as a result of
the increase to the living wage but the
crucial thing mr speaker i'm trying to
get over this afternoon is that we
unlike virtually any other european
economy have been able to keep going and
keep people uh in work and we've now got
more people in work than there were
before the pandemic began that is
because of the balanced and the
proportionate approach that we've been
taking and i think his support will be
welcomed and deserved in blackfoot
my goodness mr speaker we're talking
about etory cost of living crisis so
much for a a new year or no start
because it's the same nonsense from this
failing prime minister
we've had the
year of tory sleeves but now we've got
the year of tory squeeze for family
budgets
economists have warned that uk living
standards were worsened in 2022 but the
poorest households hit hardness by tory
cuts tax hikes and soaring inflation
driven by his government's policy
under this prime minister the uk already
has the worst levels of poverty and
inequality in northwest europe now the
tories are making millions of families
poorer in scotland the snp government is
mitigating this tory poverty crisis by
doubling the scottish child payment to
20 pounds per week so can i ask the
prime minister will he match the
scottish government and introduce a
20-pound child payment across the uk or
will the tories push hundreds of
thousands of children into poverty as a
direct result of his policies
mr speaker he's talking i'm afraid total
nonsense and we
this is a this is a government that is
absolutely determined as i've said uh
throughout this uh pandemic to look
after particularly to look after the
poorest and the neediest which is what
the chancellor did with his all his
packages were
extremely progressive in their effect
and when i came in uh to office we made
sure that we upgraded the local housing
alliance because i understand the
importance of that allowance for
families on low on low incomes we're
supporting uh vulnerable renters that's
why we're putting money into local
authorities to help uh families up and
down uh the countries who are up another
country who is uh who are facing tough
times but his fundamental point is wrong
because he's just wrong about what is
happening in this country actually if
you look at the statistics mr speaker
inequality economic inequality is down
mr speaker in this country income
inequality is down mr speaker and
poverty is down i tell you why because
we get people into work we get people
into drugs mr speaker that is our answer
robert deals
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker
the london borough of bromley has
achieved the fastest and most
significant improvement in children's
services of any local authority in
england much of that credit is due to
its exceptional chief executive mr addie
adetta soyer will my right honourable
friend join me in congratulating mr
adetosaye upon his appointment as a
commander of the british empire in the
new year's honors list and congratulate
the conservative majority on the council
on delivering the only debt-free council
in london
[Applause]
[Music]
uh well i i can't believe that
hillington isn't included in that list
uh mr speaker but uh it is no surprise
to me that bromley uh it runs such a
tight ship i've been familiar with uh
with bromley over many many years he and
i have uh have campaigned that together
i and i i commend particularly to say a
cbe on his achievement
and paul said david
happy new year mr speaker
mr speaker
i'm sure the prime minister will want to
join me and my liberal democrat
colleagues
in welcoming the new member for north
shropshire
mr speaker
people's already high heating bills are
about to jump
by over 50 percent
with average energy bills rising by
nearly 700 pounds a year
gas price rises
will push millions more families into
fuel poverty
when we know many are already afraid
even to open their heating bills
does the prime minister accept
that he could be doing much much more
than he is doing
to prevent millions of people going
hungry and cold this year
while he remains for now at least in the
warmth and comfort of number 10.
well mr speaker of course i welcome the
honourable lady to her uh to her place
uh but for the rest of what he had to
say mr think i think balls was the word
uh
i think
you were you were right first time i i
think i can
your word mr speaker not mine
and i simply i simply
advise the house to go back over what i
had just said about all the protections
that were putting in place already uh
the winter fuel payments the warm homes
allowance what we're doing to support
pensioners the 610 million pounds we're
putting into support local councils mr
speaker and
if he talks about long-term energy
solutions is this the is this the same
ed ball stroke davey uh who was an
energy minister uh mr speaker
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker hospitalization in
london have peaked so the prime minister
was absolutely right to hold his nerve
in the last few weeks but does he agree
the nhs faces not just omicron staffing
absences but permanent and dangerous
staffing shortfalls in nearly every
specialty and will he end the cycle
whereby those shortfalls continually
threaten not just patient care but
sometimes even our freedoms by
overhauling workforce planning by
backing uh baroness cumberlage's
amendment to the health bill in the
house of lords having a word with his
neighbor in downing street and making
2022 the year we finally solve this
problem yeah yeah
mr speaker i think my right honourable
friend's amendment may have re-emerged
in another in another place and i i
thank him for it he knows a great deal
about this issue and i understand what
he's what he's trying to do uh we're we
are taking uh for the time being a
different approach which is record uh
numbers of people working in our nhs
more than ever before 5 000 more doctors
this year than last year 10 000 more
nurses mr speaker that is that is thanks
to the investment that this house voted
through and that opposition unbelievably
opposed
mother
dr nancy savile was diagnosed with
dementia
just before christmas she had a stroke a
year ago
i was called to sit with her in hospital
on monday because of a kobe star
shortage but i fear
myself like many of our constituents in
similar circumstances are likely to be
separated indefinitely
when she has moved into an emi nursing
home
john's campaign has successfully
campaigned in every uk nation
the people disabled by dementia have a
special need for person-centered care
and that under the equality act 2010
but in reality there remain many care
homes and hospitals where even the most
minimal visits can be denied
leading to isolation and separation
which cause irreversible damage to
well-being
does he agree with me
that the human rights of disabled people
sick people
and the elderly are not fair weather
luxuries
and that everyone with dementia
wherever they live has the right to
family life
uh mr speaker can i first extend my my
deepest sympathies to uh the right
honourable lady and i'm sure the whole
house and everybody who's listened uh
will uh have shared her feelings and and
and and simply wish to extend their
condolences as uh in view of her
mother's current uh condition and i know
how her feelings must be exacerbated by
the difficulties that uh so many people
up and down the country are facing uh
because of the restrictions we're having
to put on on care homes and i sympathize
uh deeply
uh we do have to try to strike a balance
and to keep uh care homes residents safe
and uh and do what we can to prevent uh
the epidemic from taking hold in care
homes uh we continue to allow three
nominated visitors uh to uh two care
homes uh and there should be no uh limit
to the duration of those uh of those
visits mr speaker but i understand the
particular uh distress
and uh an anxiety that uh the radon
ladies uh circumstances are causing and
can i suggest uh that she has a meeting
uh as soon as it can be arranged with my
right-hand friend the secretary of state
for health dr caroline johnson
thank you mr speaker mr speaker many of
my constituents have contacted me with
their concerns about rising utility
bills and the high cost of fuel for
their cars
people in rural constituencies after
like sleeping in north heighten are
particularly affected by this because
the rural areas are colder in the winter
many of the homes are not on the gas
grid rural people are much more reliant
on their cars and public services are
very much further from home i would
therefore like to ask my right-hand
friend what more he can do particularly
in rural communities to ensure that my
constituents have a reliable and
affordable source of energy and fuel
i i thank her very much and she's she's
drawing attention to a very important uh
consideration as we try to uh
deal abate the the the increases in in
gas uh in the cost of gas and the cost
of the cost of energy uh so for people
in a rural constituency such as heroin
it will be an important point that we've
frozen a fuel duty uh for the 12th
year in a row that the energy price cap
itself remains in place uh clearly and
we're doing everything we can to help
people with the energy efficiency of
their homes uh what we're also doing is
all the other measures that i've i've
explained uh to the house uh but mr
speaker the most important thing that
that we can do to help people in
hercules and across the country is to
have sustainable uh clean uh cheaper
forms of energy and that is what this in
government is investing in now and we
are taking the tough decisions necessary
thank you mr speaker statutory sick pays
worth three pounds a week less in real
terms compared with the start of the
pandemic and millions of workers are
being forced to choose between isolating
and putting food on the table in germany
100 of workers salaries are covered by
sick pay whereas in the uk it is a
pitiful 19
so i asked the prime minister if he
thought earning 250 000 pounds from his
second job was chicken feed how on earth
does he expect working people to survive
on 96 pounds a week when they get sick
and if he agrees that many lives and
livelihoods could be saved by increasing
sick pay will he commit here and now to
raising it to the level of the real
living wage
mr speaker i thank the uh honorable
gentleman uh of course as he knows one
of the first things we did when we uh
when when kovitz struck was to make sure
that statutory sick pay was payable
from
day one so it's up to 75 percent uh more
more generous if you need to uh to
self-isolate and uh the the current
statutory stick pay is of course a
minimum more than a half of employees
actually get uh contractual sick pay
from that from their from their employer
but the most important thing we can do
is because ensure that we continue to
get keep people in work in jobs and in
higher wage higher skilled jobs and that
and that is what we are doing
thank you very much indeed mr speaker
later today i'll be seeking to introduce
a bill to extend auto enrollment to
pensions for everyone aged over 18
including part-time workers that would
see trillions of pounds in long-term
savings leveling up the retirements of
workers especially women in the towns
and villages of northwest durham and
across the country as the prime minister
seeks to build back better from the
global pandemic will he throw his weight
behind these important changes that
would benefit workers across our united
kingdom
over 10 million people have been
automatically enrolled into uh workplace
pensions uh already uh that's put
another 28.4 billion uh into uh into
pensions so it's a it's a great success
uh but uh i i'm sure that uh my
honourable friend the secretary of state
for for pensions will be listening
closely uh to what he's saying
thank you mr speaker and we know the
prime minister is happiest at peppa pig
world but in the in in the real world
people in southwark face rising energy
bills rising shopping costs and a new
tory tax but lee soldiers also face huge
costs for fire safety works
post-grainfield required by his
government so will the prime minister
try and keep just one promise in 2022
and protect all these holders from those
costs and will he back the cross party
campaign to make those works exempt from
vat to add a billion pounds to the
building safety fund
[Music]
i thank the the honourable uh gentleman
actually i think what most londoners uh
want is a protection from high taxing
labor councils in in my in my experience
but what they what they which is
what they will also get is we will
deliver on our on our pledge to protect
residents from uh from serious fire
safety risks and also and also to manage
uh the injustice that leaseholders uh
face mr speaker and uh the house can
look forward to being updated shortly
thank you mr speaker the very best of
british science has been on display over
the last 18 months being responsible for
the design and the manufacture of many
of the vaccines that kept us safe during
this pandemic
bayes's focus on making the uk the best
place
to practice life sciences and to
innovate is therefore welcome as is
their cluster strategy with that in mind
would my right mobile friend back
olverstone as being the pioneer place
for the cluster strategy to be rolled
out enabling high wage and high growth
jobs to be based in my constituency of
barrel and furnace
yes mr speaker because we're going to
get on with our job of leveling up
across the whole of the uk making sure
that every every part of this uh united
kingdom shares in our ambition to be a
science superpower which is uh what we
are and what we will be mr speaker
alberston has a rich history in the uh
life sciences and uh we are in uh in
regular consultation not just an
officials in uh in uh in base or in
conversations uh with uh with him and uh
with uh with officials in the sector uh
to see what more we can do for further
investments in the area
mr speaker a number of people in my
stockport constituency have contacted me
about the lack of nhs dentists and the
prohibitive cost of private dental
treatment just a few weeks ago one
constituent contacted me and said i work
full time as a mental health support
worker i'm on minimum wage and can
barely afford the reduced nhs dental
costs in the past three months i've had
to go to the emergency dentist three
times for the same tooth with the
infection initially getting so bad i
collapsed at work the problem is not
being dealt with because you need a
second appointment which isn't classed
as an emergency and thus needs your
regular dentist does the prime minister
agree that stories like this amount to
nothing less than a national scandal and
what steps will he take to reduce the
backlog of nhs dental appointments and
further will he commits to increasing
the number of nhs dentists across
england
i i i thank him but if it goes to show
why it's so important uh to keep this
country going mr speaker and to keep
people going to the to the dentist
because one of the troubles we've had
during lockdown uh people haven't been
going 10 million 10 million unfilled
fillings i'm told uh mr speaker and uh
that's why we're putting record
investment into uh into dentistry into
the nhs 36 billion pounds
for all their cattle walling mr speaker
they opposed that investment
can we remedy the current flawed
budgetary process whereby it's possible
to build 14 000 new homes in my
constituency without any commensurate
increase in general practice capacity
but as we house the next generation we
must make sure that the infrastructure
goes in at the same time
yes mr speaker and that's why we're and
i thank him and he's completely right
and you can't
build new homes without putting in the
infrastructure uh to go with it mr
speaker and that's what and that's why
and that's why we have a colossal
program of infrastructure investment uh
the biggest uh firs for a century and uh
that's why we're we're investing not
only in uh in more gps mr speaker but
another 250 million pounds into more gp
practices and they're calculating away
as usual uh they voted against that
spending
mr speaker
millions across the united kingdom are
facing great difficulty with their
energy bills
thirty percent of those bills are
actually driven by the government in the
form of vat and various green levees
now that we have left the eu prime
minister can we use our brexit freedom
to at least
review the vat on those bills and given
that some of the green levees are spent
on mad cap ideas such as subsidizing
draxby car station the tune of a billion
pounds a year to bring wood chips from
america when there's fuel down the road
can we have a review of the green levy
as well so that people are not forced
and with a burden of unsustainable fuel
bills
i i i thank the right honourable general
i can i can tell him uh that we are
addressing the uh issue of if you don't
forget the the cap is is still in place
uh mr speaker
and uh what we will do uh and all the
all the mitigations that i i've talked
about uh
are there mr speaker but we are we are
determined to do what we can to help
people through this to help people
through this pandemic and we will but
what we must do above all is make sure
this country has a better supply of
cheap and affordable energy which they
hopelessly are refused to institute
during their 13 wasted years in
government
[Music]
the speaker last week my constituent
edna constable turned 100 years old she
lived through the second world war and
now of course she's living through a
pandemic well my right honourable friend
joined me in wishing her a belated happy
birthday and we pay tribute to the care
workers who are taking care of her not
just in fountain care homes but across
my constituency and across the rest of
the country who go over and above to
protect the most vulnerable in our
society
well can i
thank him very much and say
that i want to i want to thank all the
staff at uh fountain care home and
everything that they've been doing to
look after people throughout the
pandemic but in particular i want to
join my honourable friend in wishing the
centenarian uh edna a very very happy
100th birthday
thank you mr speaker groundbreaking
research published yesterday in the
journal of psychopharmacology from
king's college london in partnership
with compass pathways has now
established that silo cybing can be
safely administered and may have
significant therapeutic benefit in
treatment resistant depression and ptsd
as someone who knows firsthand how
debilitating ptsd is as well as hearing
from many many constituents who have
developed their condition as a result of
sexual assault or their experiences
serving in our armed forces
can the prime minister today commit to a
review of the regulatory regime that
would allow for further and more rapid
research in this vital area of mental
health support for which current
treatment options are currently sorely
lacking
[Music]
i i thank her very much for her question
and
appreciate the the personal experience
that she has that that makes her
interested in psylocybin uh i i'm aware
of interest in uh in this area it's been
it's been drawn to my attention several
times i can i propose that she has a
meeting as soon as it can be arranged uh
with the relevant ministry of department
of health
apparently the government is thinking of
relaxing visa controls
from india in order to get a free trade
deal
whilst a free trade deal is valuable in
itself we should not be held to ransom
would he agree with me that our new
working-class voters who voted brexit
did not vote to replace immigration from
europe with more immigration the rest
the world
anymore that when they were told
that they would take back control we
would lose control of the channel
so will he convince us that he's
determined to connect to our supporters
and control immigration
yes yes this is the i
don't uh recognize the account he's
given at all we don't uh we don't do
free trade deals on that basis and i can
tell him actually uh that net
immigration uh since we took back
control uh has gone down uh mr speaker
and uh and uh we will continue to make
sure that we take advantage of that
that's all they want mr speaker their
answer is everywhere and always release
uh uncontrolled immigration that is
that is their approach uh to the economy
and it's not the right way forward
that's why our borders bill currently in
the house of lords is so important mr
speaker because it enables us properly
uh to take back control of our balls and
to tackle illegal immigration mr speaker
and what would be what would be good mr
speaker is to hear from support
some support from the labour benches
no question kevin blunt
thank you
mr speaker
five years ago when the prime minister
was foreign secretary um my constituent
luke simons was uh taken captive by the
houthis in yemen and unfortunately he's
got the former foreign secretary sat
next to him in another form of foreign
secretary behind him both of whom have
served during that period of time
luke simons is still in captivity uh in
sana
even though other nationalities
including the americans have managed to
get their citizens released will he uh
pledge that his government will do
everything it can
to get luke released from captivity in
the yemen
and arrange that the foreign secretary
meets with my constituent luke's
grandfather mr robert cummings uh in
order to discuss how to go about doing
that
i thank you for raising this again i i
remember the uh the case and it's a very
sad one mr speaker i know that our our
staff in the fco work very very high cdo
worked very very hard to try to release
uh people as as
around the world from the positions they
find themselves in uh luke is uh luke
simons is no exception uh to that uh but
i will certainly make sure that uh he
has a meeting with the relevant uh
minister to to report on progress we're
making
is it relevant to the question we've
just had
angela rainer
thank you mr speaker
nobody wants to mislead the house and
i'm sure the prime minister wouldn't
want to do that either earlier i quoted
the prime minister when he said that
fears about inflation were unfounded he
said he didn't say that and yet the sky
journalist beth freithbeer's now put up
this clip on social media so i'm just
wondering whether the prime minister
would like to correct the record
if the prime minister wants to come back
he can do if he doesn't what i would say
is it's not a point of order
stay there stay prime minister prime
minister
[Applause]
when you're ready i'm sorry prime
minister just to say i'm not going to
extend the debate it is a point
clarification and that's been achieved
no prime minister i am coming to you for
the statement
prime minister
mr speaker
mr speaker with your with your
permission i'll make a statement on uh
the omicron variant and our measures to
contain this virus
fortify our nhs and keep our country
open
first i'm sure the whole house will join
in paying tribute to everyone working in
our nhs and social care for their
extraordinary efforts in the teeth of
yet another wave of this pandemic and
for all they've done together with
thousands of volunteers to get britain
boosted
since we began the get boosted now
campaign just over three weeks ago we've
delivered 10 million extra boosters
across the uk
we've doubled the rate of vaccination
from 450 000 doses a day to a peak of
more than 900 000 uh we've matched the
nhs previous record day and then beaten
it again and again and we've met our
target of offering a booster to every
eligible adult in england a whole month
early
as a result we have a higher level of
booster protection than all our european
neighbors with over 34 million boosted
administered across the uk including in
england reaching more than 90 percent of
the over 70s and 86
of the over 50s
together with the evidence that omicron
causes less severe disease than previous
variants and the way the public have
conscientiously changed their behavior
in response to plan b this level of
protection means we're in a very
different position than during previous
waves
i know some honourable members might
therefore ask whether this means we can
now do away with measures altogether but
i'm sorry to report that hospital
emissions are rising rapidly doubling
around every nine days with already more
than fifteen thousand coveted patients
in hospital in england alone we're
experiencing the fastest growth in covid
cases we've ever known with over two
hundred over two hundred and eighteen
thousand cases reported yesterday
although that includes some
and that included some delayed reporting
and potentially of greatest concern case
rates are now rising rapidly among the
older and more vulnerable including
doubling every week among those over 60
with the obvious risk that this will
continue to increase the pressures on
our nhs
so in response to the latest data the
cabinet agreed this morning that we
should stick with plan b for another
three weeks with a further review before
the regulations expire on the 26th of
january
people in england should carry on
working from home whenever they can wear
face coverings on public transport and
in most indoor public places and take a
test before going to high risk venues or
meeting the elderly or vulnerable
all of these measures are helping to
take the edge off the omnicron wave slow
the spread of infection manage the
immediate pressures on our nhs and buy
time for the boosters to take effect
and those in scotland wales and northern
ireland should of course continue to
follow the rules where they live
mr speaker face with these pressures on
our nhs i know some members may ask the
opposite question whether we should go
even further and move towards a full
lockdown
the lockdowns are not cost free they
impose a devastating toll on our
physical and mental well-being on our
businesses jobs and livelihoods and
worst of all on the life chances of our
children so this government does not
believe we need to shut down our country
again
instead we are taking a balanced
approach using the protection of the
boosters and the plan b measures to
reduce the spread of the virus while
acting to strengthen our nhs protect
critical national services and keep our
supply chains open
we're building on site nightingale
hospitals and creating 2 500 virtual
beds to increase nhs capacity we've
bought more antiviral per person than
anywhere else in europe and we're now
working to identify those trusts which
are most likely to need military support
so this can be prepared now
from the 10th of january we will provide
100 000 critical workers in england with
free lateral flow tests for every
working day to help keep essential
services running this includes those who
work on critical national infrastructure
national security transport and food
distribution and processing and these
tests are separate and in addition to
those already allocated to our public
services such as in education where we
have delivered 31 million testing tests
testing kits to schools and colleges for
the start of the new term mr speaker we
have the biggest testing program in
europe registering almost twice as many
tests as france and four times as many
as germany
last month alone we distributed 300
million natural flow devices enabling
millions of people to get taste tested
and keep their loved ones friends and
colleagues safe in the run-up to
christmas but thanks to the sheer size
of the omicron wave we still need to
take steps to ensure our testing
capacity reaches those who need it most
so we will be suspending the need to do
a pcr to confirm the result of a
positive lateral flow test from next
tuesday in england if you test positive
on a lateral flow device you should just
record that result on gov dot uk and
begin self-isolating mr speaker our
balanced approach also means that where
specific measures are no longer serving
their purpose they will be dropped so
when the omicron variant was first
identified we rightly introduced travel
restrictions to slow its arrival in our
country
but now omicron is so prevalent these
measures are having limited impact on
the growth in cases while continuing to
pose significant costs to our travel
industry so i can announce it in england
from 4am on friday we will be scrapping
the pre-departure test which discourages
many from traveling for fear of being
trapped overseas and incurring
significant extra expense we will also
be lifting the requirement to
self-isolate on arrival until receipt of
a negative pcr returning instead to the
system we had in october last year where
those arriving in england will need to
take a lateral flow test no later than
the end of day two and if positive a
further pcr test to help us identify any
new variants at the border
mr speaker all these measures are
balanced and proportionate ways of
ensuring we can live with kobed without
letting our guard down and we can only
do this thanks to the biggest and
fastest booster campaign in europe yet
mr speaker there are still almost nine
million people eligible who have not had
their booster as many as 90 percent of
those in intensive care with kobe have
not had their booster and over 60
percent in intensive care have not had
any with kovid have not had any
vaccination at all and there are two
million slots available in the next week
alone so i urge honourable members on
all sides of the house to do everything
possible to encourage your constituents
to get boosted now this is the very best
way to save lives reduce pressure on our
nhs and keep our country open and i
commend this statement to the house
the leader of the opposition
thank you mr speaker and can i thank the
prime minister for advanced sight of his
statement and can i wholeheartedly back
him in asking people to come forward to
get their booster jobs and to get their
jobs and of course it's right that plan
b measures must stay in place during
this wave of the pandemic
it was the labour party who made sure
the government had the votes to pass
these measures through this house and if
it wasn't for labour's actions the nhs
would be facing even greater pressures
and the likelihood is we would have
needed much harsher restrictions
and my message to the prime minister
today is despite the people sat behind
him and those eyeing up his job
alongside him labor will always act in
the national interest and put the public
health before party politics
[Music]
now the prime minister said we have to
ride out this omicron wave
but the nhs isn't surfing it's
struggling to stay afloat
we've now seen several hospital trusts
declare critical incidents meaning they
are unable to provide services for
cancer and heart disease patients
in my home of greater manchester
non-urgent surgery is being halted
i thank those trusts who have come
forward and been upfront about the
reality that they are facing and our nhs
staff who are going above and beyond
once again to get us through this period
isn't it time for the prime minister to
be straight with people and give a frank
assessment of the state of our nhs he
mentions the use of the army but how
many trusts have declared a critical
incident and what does the prime
minister plan to do about it
people in the north east are being told
to call a cab or phone a friend if they
are suffering a suspected heart attack
or stroke as shocking mr speaker
but even before omicron hit thousands of
suspected heart attack and stroke
victims in england were forced to wait
over a one hour and 40 minutes for their
ambulance
isn't the truth that our health service
went into this wave of infections with
the largest waiting list on record the
longest waiting times on record and
major staff shortages
after a decade of touring mismanagement
the nhs wasn't prepared for covid and
didn't have the space their capacity to
cope with omicron
it's not just that the conservatives
didn't fix the roof when the sun was
shining they dismantled the roof and
removed the floorboards
[Music]
now mr speaker
getting testing right remains the best
way to avoid further restrictions it's
welcome that the government is requiring
daily testing to protect critical
national infrastructure but this won't
begin until next week and our essential
services are buckling under the pressure
right now doctors nurses carers teachers
and pupils can't get the test they need
now to do two tests a week emergency
workers are reportedly stuck in
isolation because they can't get their
hands on a test
so why did the health secretary claim on
the 13th of december that there is no
shortage of actual tests
why was the government's delivery
service allowed to go on holiday over
christmas with no contingency plan in
place the government has been asleep at
the wheel mr speaker and the result is
total shambles
i'm sure the prime minister will join me
in thanking the welsh labour government
for sharing four million tests with
england thank goodness they had the
foresight to plan ahead and secure
enough tests for this period
mr speaker in april 2020 the government
published a strategy to scale up covid
19 testing programmes they promised to
work with the uk's world's leading
diagnostic companies to build a british
diagnostics industry at scale
yet two years on this has never
materialized how much taxpayers money
was spent on this program and why prime
minister two years into the pandemic are
we still relying on tests from china
instead of building the capacity to make
the test here in britain why are you
buying abroad mr speaker people he can
shudder away but he'll have his
opportunity in a minute people will be
returning to work this week but the
government is refusing to guarantee all
workers sufficient sick pay leaving
working people with the choice of going
to work to feed their families or
staying at home to protect public health
will the prime minister finally raise
sick pay so that people are no longer
faced with an impossible choice of doing
the right thing or feeding their family
and mr speaker
in some of the poorest countries in the
world
less than 10
of the population are vaccinated this is
shameful
we know we can do more to assist the
international vaccine efforts and what
is the government doing about this and
if we are going to break this endless
cycle of new variants we have to
vaccinate the world this is not just a
question of doing the right thing for
others it's in our national interest too
finally mr speaker
there are conservative members sat
behind the prime minister who have spent
recent weeks attacking hard-working
public servants isn't it time isn't it
time that the prime minister stood by
our experts professionals and officials
that are doing all they can to protect
public health if he was happy to defend
dominic cummings the former health
secretary and owen patterson why won't
he defend those public servants who are
actually doing the right thing
[Music]
[Applause]
mr speaker when it comes to attacking
hard-working public servants why does
she continue to attack our testing
operation for instance mr speaker which
has done a fantastic job uh throughout
this pandemic and and and there were
several things in that uh in that
intervention mr speaker which was simply
completely the inverse of the of the
truth uh we are not cutting uh cancer
services mr speaker we've invested more
in uh in oncologists we've got four
percent more oncologists uh this year
than last year five percent more
radiologists and uh she asked about she
asked about uh ambulances and yes of
course everybody should get an ambulance
uh who needs one that's why we've
invested um 55 million more in the
ambulance service there are 500 more
ambulance staff now than there were in
2018 mr speaker 10 000 more nurses 5 000
more doctors than there were last year
and that is because the investment that
we are making uh 36 billion pounds uh
every penny piece of which they voted
against uh mr speaker she
to come to testing i mean it really it
really is extraordinary uh that they
could they run down this country and
it's achieved time and time time and
time again look uh mr speaker uh we're
doing 520 000 pcr tests every day 1.25
million tests every day we've tested 400
million done 400 million tests in the
country more tests per head in in this
country than any other european country
she talks about schools we delivered 31
million tests
to schools in the run-up in the run-up
to christmas uh and she made an
incredible point this is because she
said that this country didn't have its
own diagnostics capabilities she doesn't
know what this country is doing
unbelievable
so we have a lot let me tell let me tell
the opposition front bench we have the
largest lateral flow manufacturing
company uh facility in this country use
in this country in this go and visit it
mr speaker they don't know what they're
talking about
it's it's in nottingham uh mr speaker
and we buy and we buy them all and uh
and by the way
talk she talks about the testing regime
it's thanks to the efficiency of our
testing regime that the leader of the
opposition whom we wish well uh is uh is
not currently in his place yes uh it's
thanks to the uh the testing regime is
because she's able to speak from that
dispatch box at all
so
so she might as well she might as well
support it uh mr speaker they've done
they've done an incredible job uh
two two final points mr speaker they
voted they voted continually against uh
our funding for the nhs that has made uh
we'll have made this possible uh and and
they and let's be in no doubt they would
have kept this country in lockdown from
july the 19th they they were they were
opposing and and she and and
and
members of the front bench uh chorused
that we needed tougher restrictions as
we came into uh into omicron and they
said we needed a roadmap for lockdown
that was their approach and what's that
what would have been the result mr
speaker and another body blow to the uk
economy and to our ability to fund our
nhs and that is the fundamental
difference between that is the
fundamental difference between this
government and that opposition we have a
plan for getting through kobe all they
do is carp from the sidelines
thank you thank you mr speaker may i
commend my right honourable friend for
resisting calls from the labour party
and others for more
restrictions and also for the changes
that he has announced today
omicron is less serious than previous
variants we will see new variants appear
in future and the likelihood is that
they will continue to be less serious it
is not in the national interest
to partially or wholly shut down sectors
of our economy every time we see a new
variant
so will my right honourable friend take
this opportunity to inform the house as
to whether and how the government will
be changing its approach when new
variants arrive
[Music]
i thank uh my right on friend very much
and of course she's she's totally right
in what she says uh we simply cannot go
on as a country and as a as a society by
reaching endlessly for uh the the the
for lockdown which is their which is
their instinct no matter what the cost
no matter what the damage uh it does we
have to remain uh cautious uh mr speaker
and i'm afraid i can't tell the house
that we can rule out absolutely
everything to protect the public but i
am confident as i said to the country
last night i'm confident mr speaker
that's why i'm repeating it today i'm
confident that we can get through uh
this wave of omicron uh with the
measures uh with the balanced and
proportionate approach that we are
taking and i'm glad uh to have her
support mr speaker and for the future
what we need is the multivalent the
polyvalent vaccines that can deal with
any with any type of of covid mutation
any type of variant as well as the
therapeutics
speaker and that is what we're investing
in as well and she should know more
beheaded than any any other country in
europe yeah they do have the snp in
platforms you're here thank you mr
speaker can i thank the prime minister
for advanced site of his statement i
hope the
prime minister had a
safe and restful break and his festive
parties but perhaps more sensible and
legal than they were in 2020.
mr speaker the prime minister is right
that the booster program is absolutely
crucial
getting a booster reduces the chance of
getting covet protects against serious
illness and helps reduce pressure on our
nhs
but the prime minister's central
approach to ride out the omercon wave is
a reckless gamble that risks lives and
risks to nhs
let's talk about
what ride it out means it means allowing
the omicron variant to rip through
communities it means avoidable deaths
long covered and stretching the nhs the
breaking point that's why
the correct approach is to show
continued caution and to slow
transmission
this is the proactive sensible and
cautious approach been taken by the
scottish government and the other
devolved nations and it is a uk
government that is once again out of
step
but recklessness has been the hallmark
of this prime minister
the prime minister has acknowledged
parts of the nhs will feel temporarily
overwhelmed
but hospitals in england are already
overwhelmed with heart attack patients
been told to make their own way to
hospitals how appalling prime minister
what a failure so will the prime
minister now listen to his own chief
scientific advisor and chief medical
officers who've acknowledged that the
disease is moving up the aid ranges and
that we can expect increased pressures
on hospital and will the prime minister
act to slow the rate of transmission mr
speaker
the reality is
that the prime minister has no choice
but to ride it out because he's too weak
to get a more cautious and sensible
approach but past his divided cabinet
and his mutinous back benches and the
prime minister knows that he doesn't
carry the moral authority to protect the
public when he's broken previous
restrictions himself
the public is faced with a prime
minister who does not have the political
leadership or the authority to act to
keep these islands safe so while the
prime minister finally acknowledged that
he's riding it out is risking lies and
the nhs because his back benchers are
now calling us shots
well mr speaker that
take back what he said uh because uh
because
you know mr speaker because i tell you
what i do i think that he should be he
should be respectful of the traditions
of this house uh which is you don't
accuse people of things that they
haven't done mr speaker and it is
totally untrue this government this
government has taken a ba order order or
or
publishing
mr blackford
please we just want to calm it down this
is a new year let's start off as we mean
to go on not in the way that we're
behaving
no no
prime minister
well mr speaker while that while the
scottish national party continues to do
a serious economic damage uh in the way
that they do uh we will con we we will
we will continue to get on uh with a
balanced and
a balanced and a proportionate
or order
order
now either we behave
or i don't need any advice from anybody
over there either that's the last thing
we need i'm just saying i think we just
need to calm it down it's a very
important debate the country is watching
they want to hear what's going on cat
calling across the chamber is not good
for anybody prime minister
i am grateful mr speaker uh and i think
that what we i need to do is get on
together uh with a plan that is both
balanced and proportionate and i think
uh does a huge amount to protect the
public and is the right way forward in
dealing with omicron and he says mr
speaker that uh the uk government is out
of step with what uh scottish
nationalist party one actually
overwhelmingly uh we do the same thing
at the same time and there is far more
uh that unites us than divides us and
that is that is the reality you may not
like it but that is the reality and
uh uh mr speaker uh
i i must say i do take exception uh to
the language used by the uh the right
honourable gentleman and uh mr speaker i
i just i i think that when it comes to
the union he should reflect on the
the great success that has been achieved
by uh uk scientists working together on
vaccines the the formidable effort of of
test and trace operations that i've seen
myself in glasgow and elsewhere uh the
the heroic actions of the the british
army uh in ferrying uh
vulnerable people uh who needed urgent
coveted treatment uh from remote
scottish islands to the places where
they needed care uh to to furlough which
was a huge operation uh many billions of
which were spent in scotland and an
enough and a fine thing to and i think
he should take back some of his more uh
intemperate remarks i don't think they
do him any credit at all and i think
what we should do is do our level best
to work together in a civilized and
collegiate way to get through this
pandemic and that is what this
government intends to do
can i just say i didn't hear what was
said because people are children at the
same time i want it to calm it down i
want to assume language that is
appropriate to this chamber so please
make sure that we treat each other with
the respect that i expect from all of
you going forward bob sealer
mr speaker
i congratulate the prime minister on his
balanced approach unlike that of some
other people in this house
there is increasing concern amongst
epidemiologists modelers oncologists and
scientists about the use of modeling and
forecasts amongst the comments are that
the forecasts which we may have been
using for the last two years are almost
hysterical lurid spectacularly wrong
consistently overconfident and
substantially inflated and those are
comments from scientists not from
journalists or politicians does he trust
the modeling that he is getting and
would the government consider an inquiry
into the use of modeling and forecast
many of which have been found to be
unrelated to reality
prime minister i thank my honorable
friend very much and i think it's very
important for everybody to understand
the limitations of what a model is these
are not forecasts they're they're
mathematical projections based on the
data that the uh the model is currently
have but particularly when it came to
omicron about severity of the disease
and uh and that is why when you feed uh
the assumptions about severity uh that
are excessive uh into the models you
will get uh results uh that come out uh
excessive and and that i think is what
he's uh what he's driving at uh i think
if you look at some of the uh the model
some of the calculations they're much
closer uh to what is in fact happening
uh now models are useful they can't be
uh dispensed with uh you need to have
projections what i don't think uh we
should be doing in this house uh is uh
in any way trying to undermine or attack
the independent scientists uh whose uh
whose independence is absolutely vital
for our ability to handle this disease
chris brown
josh thank you mr speaker
let's
um can i ask the prime minister he knows
perfectly well that one of the big
issues facing the nhs is capacity in
particular in the workforce can i just
make some very simple suggestions that
could could have an effect very very
quickly first of all to provide to
reward people for staying on in the nhs
right the way through to retirement to
reward people for returning from
retirement
to make sure that we deal with the
gender pay gap because that's what's
making it very difficult for many women
to stay on in the profession provide
sabbaticals so that people don't burn
out in the profession
and finally deal with the problem of
overtime which is now which is now
barely worth doing for lots of doctors
and nurses if we increase that maybe
we'll be able to increase the capacity
and be able to save many more lives
i thank uh the right on general we are
doing everything we can to ensure
flexibility in the uh in the nhs so that
uh staff can move uh more easily with
that by electronic uh passes and so on
from one uh place to uh to another we're
getting many many doctors back to the uh
to the service uh we've got to our
volunteers as you know both in uh both
in the vaccine rollout and now in
helping hospitals with the current uh
with the current pressure uh but for
more fundamentally what we're doing is
recruiting uh large numbers of of nhs
staff and uh the there are now more
people working in the nhs at any time in
its uh in its history uh about 50 000 uh
more all told uh this year than last
year uh and uh that is as a result of
the investments uh that we're making
red claw thank you very much indeed mr
speaker i welcome the changes that the
prime minister has announced uh all of
us should want to be protected by
vaccines rather than restrictions uh in
the future
he'll be aware that on new year's eve
the uk health security agency uh
published a report that says that
booster doses wane in their protection
against infection but not against severe
disease
after 10 weeks
given that nhs and care workers
started having their booster doses in
the middle of september
over six weeks 16 weeks ago now is it
right to consider these vital workers
should be given a fourth uh dose as is
happening for similar workers in israel
prime minister i i i thank my uh my
royal friend i think he's making a very
uh important point i know that the uh
the jcbi is continuing to keep
fourth
jabs under under continuous review
mr speaker parents teachers and pupils
are incredibly nervous
that due to the unprecedented spike in
covert numbers children might once again
face hundreds of thousands of hours of
lost learning
the reality is that due to staff
shortages many of our schools are at
breaking point an entire generation has
already lost years of learning that they
might never get back
so will the prime minister do the right
thing
and properly fund a catch-up program
starting by providing every parent with
a 30 pound catch-up voucher for every
day their child misses school mr speaker
this government is not only letting down
millions of children but by
short-changing them damaging the future
of our country
prime minister
uh mr speaker that's why it's so
important to keep schools open that's
why uh it's so important to take the
balanced and proportionate approach that
we uh that we have and uh and and and
it's
it's that's why it's very important to
to ensure that schools are safe and i
thank parents and teachers for
everything uh that they are doing but
he's wrong about what he says about
catch up we're investing massively in
catch up we've got a five billion pound
program of investment in catch up mr
speaker and we're we are innovating the
whole time particularly with investment
in one to one uh tuition or one to two
or three uh tuition for kids who need it
and and that is a a huge development
which is of massive benefit uh to uh
pupils up and down the country yeah
rainbow
thank you mr speaker and can i thank the
prime minister for his statement today
and also to people like dr tim cooper in
my constituency who took up the prime
minister's challenge and enabled
absolutely everybody eligible in my
constituency to be able to have their
boosters over the christmas period with
walking clinics continuing until sunday
of this week um but can the prime
minister also uh take care to remember
some particularly younger residents who
have had kovid and have had to wait
until they can have their booster
through no fault of their own and can
the situation of those individuals be
taken into account if any new measures
are considered um or indeed whether he
can think about ways that we could
perhaps ease the restrictions on their
access to boosters
prime minister my ronald mcdonald makes
a very important point
it's a fundamental a point about
fairness
so i think it was raised with me last
night in the press conference i think by
uh one of the public uh questioners uh
it wouldn't be fair to insist on
boosters uh as
uh meaning that you've been uh
vaccinated until young people in
particular have had a chance to get
boosted
thank you uh mr speaker mr speaker we've
seen a huge demand for uh tests for lft
test doesn't mean this the prime
minister regret his press conference
where he urged everyone to get tested
tested tested without making sure that
there was supplies necessary to deliver
no mr speaker because it's thanks to the
efforts of the uh nhs the testing
operation that we've uh been and and
testing manufacturers uh not just around
the world but in this country uh a
stupefying ignorance displayed by uh the
labor front bench uh which means that
we've been able to triple our testing
capacity and we are testing more behead
than any other european country usually
they love these european statistics uh
mr speaker
they they seem a bit shy about this one
but that is the that is the reality
testing is a a good thing it's very
important that people do it and uh and
and people should certainly get
attention yeah steve baker mr speaker
and um i've certainly disagreed
occasionally with my right honourable
friend in the course of this crisis but
i also certainly credit him with doing
his very level best to preserve freedom
and lives and prosperity in this country
but he'll know as i know that the public
are now yearning to know when we're
going to get back to the old normal
investors need to know the wider public
need to know and every business person
in the country needs to know when the
sword of damocles won't be hanging over
them of further restrictions will you
please bring forward a plan to get back
to the old normal
prime minister thank you i thank my my
right-hand friend that the plan is the
is the one that we have
in place and uh it is to it is to uh to
get on with uh with plan b uh and there
will be a review point as as as he knows
it expires as he knows on the 26th of of
this month uh the plan b measures but by
then uh we hope to have greatly
increased the already extraordinarily
high number of people in this country
who have not only been vaccinated but
who have been boosted now the the number
of people have been boosted in the uk is
currently 34 million mr speaker
there are now there are a further nine
million uh that we need to reach uh but
we've already offered as i said uh to
the house before christmas our plan was
to double the speed of the booster
rollout which we did we've offered a
slot to everybody uh who every eligible
adult got a slot before uh before new
year what we need to do now is increase
that uh number of uh of boosted members
of the population and then as omicron
blows through and i you know it is very
much my hope and belief that it will i
do believe uh that we will be able to
get back to something much closer to
normality that doesn't mean that there
won't be further challenges but i think
that life will return to something much
much closer uh to normality it won't be
necessary uh to uh to have the
restrictions that we currently have in
place business investors uh will have
all the confidence that they that they
need but to be frank or mr speaker
you're already seeing a huge investment
in this country because of the approach
that we've taken
i think i need to help a little bit
prime minister i am here not that way to
help us all
yeah but the other thing i would say is
i don't want to keep you here forever
but with a lot of people who are
standing who do want to hear from you so
it might be easier for yourself if you
could short some of the answers johnna
cherry thank you mr speaker um at prime
minister's questions my honourable
friend the member for dwever marienneth
very movingly raised the plight of care
home residents who've been left without
visits from their loved ones during the
pandemic
especially a care home residents with
dementia
the joint committee on human rights have
repeatedly raised our concerns about
care homes implementing highly
restrictive visiting rules
potentially contrary to the government's
own guidance and in contravention
of the human rights of residents and
loved ones and we've recommended that
proper individualized risk assessments
be carried out in all cases now i noted
the prime minister's sympathy for the
plight of my honorable friend and her
mother but can you tell me this what
specific steps will his government take
to make sure that visiting restrictions
are proportionate across the board
prime minister i thank her very much and
i want to repeat my sympathy for all
those who need to visit people in care
homes and uh for loved ones in care
homes who are desperate to be visited we
we have the system in place which does
allow uh for unlimited uh duration uh
visits for three nominated persons as i
as i said which is an improvement if she
remembers on where we were at at earlier
stages in this in this pandemic but uh
what we want to do is continue with a
balanced and proportionate approach
doesn't allow uh the the disease to get
back into uh care homes in the way that
it did uh and the faster we can get uh
through omicron uh the quicker we'll be
back to normal
congratulate him on these nighthood
matt thank you mr speaker i'm sure we
were on this side of the house warmly
welcome my right on defense statement
and i've had the honor of joining an
army of volunteers at my local
vaccination hub over christmas to help
get people jabbed now thousands of
people every day it's been a huge
privilege
my local hospital the great western
hospital has declared internal uh
critical incident i would be extremely
grateful to him and his quality of
health secretary to receive maximum
assurance that the leadership at that
hospital will get all the support they
need in order to maintain those
essential services for the people of my
constituency and beyond
prime minister
uh yes mr speaker and i i
echo your congratulations of course uh
to my right honourable friend and his uh
the hospital he mentions will get every
uh support uh throughout this difficult
period and we we will do uh
everything we can to engage with my uh
right on offender uh
on on the issues he raises but that
support is made possible that i told the
house through the funding we're putting
in
david
thank you uh mr speaker i wonder mr
speaker if the prime minister would uh
take the opportunity and to join me in
thanking the welsh labour government for
sharing
four million tests with england
uh actually mr speaker that the uk
government supplied tests to the whole
country uh but we're very very proud to
collaborate uh with people and testing
organizations across the country yeah
robert
can i thank the prime minister whose
judgment was proven to be absolutely
correct over the holidays as a parent
the wearing of a mask at school may seem
a small price to pay to ensure that your
kids are back in the classroom getting
the vital face-to-face teaching that
they deserve but it isn't cost-free it
does affect the quality of teaching and
the well-built well-being of our
children so what assurance can my writer
friend give me and parents across the
country that this measure will be
constantly reviewed and will only last
as long as absolutely necessary
i can give him a categorical insurance
mr speaker that uh masters in schools
will not last a day more uh than we need
them
um
absolutely you mr speaker
winter is always a difficult time for
the nhs but we are now in an
unsustainable situation last night 17
hospitals across greater manchester
announced that they were suspending
non-urgent surgeries due to the impact
of covet
19.
and at least 10 trucks across england
have already been forced to declare
critical incidents since christmas
last week the prime minister said he
hoped we could ride out this wave but i
don't think our hard-working nhs staff
or the government scientific advisors
would agree
what additional steps will he now take
to ensure greater manchester's hospital
do not become
critically overwhelmed
prime minister
mr speaker what we're doing is to
support hospitals in greater manchester
and uh up and down the country uh with
record investment but also uh making
sure that we uh as as i
was saying to an earlier answer making
sure that we uh supplement the staff uh
with uh all the recording doctors back
to the colors uh volunteers and a new
therapeutic treatments and and all those
uh extra things that we're doing mr
speaker but fundamentally there's also a
job for this country to follow plan b
follow the guidance uh that we've put in
place and get boosted that's the most
important thing we can do
hurry in baldwin
thank you very much mr speaker and uh
can i warmly welcome the boost that the
prime minister gave to the get boosted
now program over the recess um almost a
million boosts a day were given to
people i want to thank everyone involved
in that also welcome the leadership that
pm showed uh on the kovacs facility and
making sure that vaccinations have been
spread around the world is there more
that we can do given the risk of
variance emerging in places where
vaccination rates are not as high as in
the uk um to boost vaccination rates
around the world
uh i i i think i think the uk could be
proud of
what when she knows this area well what
we're doing uh to support vaccination
around the
the world uh thanks to the deal we did
uh with astrazeneca oxford uh oxford
astrazeneca uh 1.5 billion doses were
administered to uh to people who uh
needed them around the role at cost that
was thanks to the deal negotiated by the
uk government uh we put 478 million into
into kovacs and we have a pledge to
deliver 100 million uh surplus vaccines
around the world uh by uh by june this
year kim blackbeat
thank you mr speaker throughout the
pandemic people in education have worked
heroically to keep our schools open and
children learning
but they are struggling i spoke to a
head teacher in my constituency this
morning who is currently working as a
school caretaker receptionist classroom
teacher and covic tester
can the prime minister at least admit to
overstretched staff working in education
that communication with schools needs to
be better and that more could and should
have been done before schools returned
to prevent this highly predictable
situation
prime minister well mr speaker i i look
i share what she said about the amazing
work that's being done by by teachers
and schools up and down the country and
i've been to many of them and they've
done incredible things uh to make their
schools covered compliant to protect
against uh infection and they've done a
a fantastic job uh we communicate with
them as uh
the whole time and my right or friend
the secretary of state for education i
think has done a formidable job
of uh of of interacting with uh with
teachers with uh with parents and trying
to get our messages uh across uh and i i
know that uh she'll want to be in the
chamber for the statement that my our
animal friend is about to make
andrew percy thank you mr speaker in
their critique i think the opposition
front bench forgot about the 50 000
hospital beds they cut when they were in
power including closing entire awards at
ghoul hospital
but but i digress mr speaker can i
remind the prime minister of the
important role volunteers are
undertaking in the nhs at the moment
particularly those
in services such as the ambulance
service who will be attending more and
more
jobs uh in the coming weeks and months
to support our nhs and given we're going
to be relying on our nhs to quite
rightly keep the economy open can i ask
him to look closely at possible future
reward and recognition payments to our
nhs staff for the extra efforts they'll
be making this winter
prime minister i i thank him very much
and he making an incredibly important
point about uh the record of the uh of
the opposition uh because uh the the
pressure the pressure the pressure on
the on on the nhs
the pressure and the pressure on the nhs
is caused uh by the the limit to the
number of uh beds we have only about a
hundred thousand and and mr speaker that
is why this government is getting on
with building 40 more hospitals yes we
are yes we are and that's why we're
recruiting 50 000 more nurses mr speaker
and they opposed a lot of it we're in
bed
until now the advice
to care homes has been that if someone
tests positive
with a pcr test they should not be
tested using a pcr or
a lateral flow test for 90 days
unless they develop new symptoms during
this time in which case they should be
retested immediately
using a pcr test given the changes to
the testing arrangements he's announced
today does this advice still hold yeah
good question
no it doesn't mr speaker and i'll make
sure that he is advised on the new
arrangements david morris
thank you mr speaker mr speaker the more
convey health trust has been overwhelmed
recently
with people in effect bed blocking
because they can't get back into the
into the care homes um
i know that we're putting tents on car
parks i've seen that on the news
i would like to say in a very helpful
way do not think it would be right to
enact in areas like mine more sort of
rural areas going north the big
nightingale centers like we had in
preston
prime minister i i'm very grateful to uh
my honorable friend but actually what we
are uh what we're doing is making sure
that uh we support uh hospitals up and
down the country who are facing uh the
pressures he he describes uh not just
with uh with more staff but also with
more facilities with on-site
nightingales as i said uh in my
statement
thank you mr speaker
my honourable friend the member for
easton barton chair along with the
honourable members for chatham and
aylesford bradford west and northeast
fife all of whom have been affected by
the lack of proxy voting and remote
participation have jointly written to
the leader of the house seeking the
reintroduction of remote provision
clearly this is not just a covert issue
but we can certainly see now how much
it's needed and it matters because as
things stand parliament is excluding mps
and disenfranchising their constituents
so will the prime minister throw his
weight behind their calls to modernize
and ensure that no member is prevented
from fully representing their
constituents
prime minister i i'm grateful tony and i
think i should speak for everybody here
what we want to see is the house getting
back to normal uh business as fast as as
possible and to that end i think i
suggest that everybody follows the
guidelines and get boosted
steve bryan
very much mr speaker the prime minister
deserves real credit i think for his
recent decisions with respect to covid
he's followed the evidence but he's also
taken i think the wider view of our
society and our economy which has to be
right in my opinion england is not out
of step with scotland and wales they're
out of step with us
can i ask my right honourable friend to
also though take the long view because
it's increasingly clear we're a long way
from learning to live with kobe but we
also have an nhs on a permanent war
footing and that's not sustainable so
what is the long term plan for living
with coving in 2022
and could that include any changes to
mandatory isolation and test and trace
as for instance we see different
isolation dates in the us and germany to
here in the uk
uh i'm grateful to uh
my
we will continue to keep isolation uh
timings under review uh we don't want to
release people back into uh society so
soon that they uh their workplace they
just infect all their or their
colleagues that would not be uh would
not be sensible but as i said in my
earlier answers mr speaker i do think
that we have a good chance of of getting
through this difficult uh wave and
getting back to something like uh
normality uh as fast as possible and
it is it is important that kovid that uh
that omicron uh is uh seems to uh
provide some sort of immunity for
instance against delta that may be a
positive augury uh for the future mr
speaker kevin jones i thank the prime
minister for his uh statement it is
announced that uh those testing positive
for the lateral flow test will no longer
have to go for a pcr test
uh but there will be down to the
individual to actually inform the
government of the result can i ask what
percentage do you think will do that
more importantly that won't do that and
as pcr tests are important for analyzing
the genome
of the virus what effect will that
non-reporting have on our ability to
actually look at new variants which will
develop
i i'm grateful but i must say that
throughout this pandemic it is the has
been the public
who have continually uh surprised on the
upside uh with their determination to
take this seriously uh mr speaker and
and a very very and and rather than
undermining confidence in them a very
very high proportion of them uh continue
to do uh the right thing and and i
believe always will
carpo
thank you very much um mr speaker can i
press the prime minister on a couple of
previous answers um he will know that
he's obviously come to the house today
to extend plan b restrictions for a
further three weeks he'll also know that
the chief scientific advisor said that
covert is going to be with us forever
we're going to have variance forever so
can i press him on his answer to the uh
our right honourable friend the member
for maidenhead about an exit strategy we
cannot respond every new variant
in the way we have to this one we have
got to have a plan
to live with this virus
like normal forever
when is he going to set that plan out in
this house
so that we all know where we stand
prime minister
actually mr speaker if he uh if he looks
at what we're uh we're doing we the the
measures we have in place expire on
january the uh 26th as he knows uh and
uh
whatever the uh the situation may be
then and i'm confident that it will be
much better whatever the situation may
be mr speaker we will continue with
the fundamental uh
the
tools that we have that is vaccination
therapeutics and testing uh mr speaker
but it is important it is important
that omicron
seems to provide
some sort of immunity already against
delta and that i think is a point that
he should feed in his capacious brain
welcome the new member helen morgan
thank you mr speaker
ambulance services and paramedics are
desperately struggling to maintain a
safe and timely service across the
country my constituency of north
structure is no exception and
inexplicable inexplicably you've seen
two of its ambulance stations close as
well as waiting times skyrocket
with the crisis in emergency care
escalating will the prime minister
commit today before this house to
supporting my call for a full and proper
review of ambulance services by the care
quality commission
prime minister speak
it's very important everyone should get
the ambulance service that that they
need and that's why that's why we're
we're investing uh 55 million more and
that's why there are 500 people more in
the on the ambulance staff than they
were in 2018.
mr speaker is my right honourable friend
or when
that the eyes of the world are literally
upon us
with the new york times and newspapers
in france germany and israel among
others talking about the prime
minister's bold initiative in sticking
to plan b and recognizing that omicron
is less serious than previous variants
they say
that britain was the first to recognize
that that we were the first to start a
vaccine program in europe
and also the largest testing program in
europe and i asked my right honorable
friend will he still however maintain a
watching brief on other variants because
there may be more serious variants in
the future we just don't know and would
you also take this opportunity again of
correcting what the deputy leader of the
opposition said and say that we are not
cancelling any
cancer operations
yes indeed mr speaker and i i really
think that she should uh withdraw that
because uh it is not she did say that mr
speaker she did say that and it was she
did it was totally untrue but mr speaker
it's because we are the most boosted uh
the most tested and uh because we have
the most antivirals of any uh european
country that we're able uh also to be
the most open and that is thanks to the
efforts of this government but
hundreds of thousands of people up and
down the country millions of people who
are doing the right thing
completely forgot
thank you mr speaker nhs workers say
they are broken they're overworked
exhausted and undervalued
pushed to the brink before the pandemic
now abandoned by the government
so will the prime minister listen to
workers and trade unions and actually
support nhs staff by protecting doctors
and nurses who treat coveted patients by
giving them ffp3 masks and properly
rewarding them not with claps or pay
rises that are actually pay cuts when
you take inflation above five percent
into account but with a genuine pay rise
of 15
making up a decade of falling pay and if
he asks how are we going to pay for it
he can look at the 37 billion pounds put
towards the privatized test and trace
budget
mr speaker you know i really think that
she should listen to uh to what's
actually going on in this country today
uh we're we're investing record sums in
the nhs there are 5 000 more doctors and
10 000 more nurses
now than there were last year there are
record numbers of people in the nhs and
that in my experience is what nhs staff
want to see in addition to the extra
money we've put into into pay rises
that's been made possible through the 36
billion pounds that we have voted uh
through and which she opposed maybe she
didn't mr speaker but i think the record
will show that she voted against it
dr carol angels
thank you mr speaker mr speaker united
linking to hospitals declared a critical
incident on january the 1st this is not
due to the number of omicron patients
but due to pressures on staffing caused
by immigrant cases and by
isolation pressures local mps have been
reassured that acute services are safe
and are open will my writing and friend
join me in thanking the staff of united
lincoln's hospitals for their work dead
and dedication under extraordinary
circumstances and will he give me his
assurance that he will do all he can and
his government will provide all the
support that is necessary to united
linkage hospitals
i i thank her very much and i know uh
united nation hospital uh i i've been i
think i've
i remember going there with the former
uh health secretary whose grandmother uh
worked there if i recall correctly and i
know what an incredible uh job they do i
know how difficult it has been uh for
them uh mr speaker and as i said to the
house and to the country it will
continue to be difficult in the course
of the next few weeks but we will get
through it and we will give the nhs all
the support it needs
stephanie
thank you mr speaker average pay in
barnsley is in the lowest 30 in the
country and those on lower incomes are
more likely to rely on statutory sick
pay does the prime minister accept that
the shockingly low levels of sick pay in
this country will impact the number of
people able to isolate and can i ask him
again to commit to increasing it
prime minister mr speaker as i as i said
in an earlier answer uh we we've made
sure that uh sick pay for those who are
isolating uh
kicks in on on day one that's equivalent
to a 75
increase uh but what we're also doing mr
speaker because i do appreciate that uh
some families are finding it very tough
at them at the moment we're increasing
that hardship fund 500 million a
hardship fund that is available through
local councils uh to help people through
a difficult time what would not be
sensible mr speaker is to follow the
advice of so many on the opposition
ventures and go for tougher measures
lock down the uh economy uh which would
be which would be something that would
impoverish uh the people of this country
yeah congratulating him on his nighttime
bill we're good william wiggins
and my right honourable friend has
touched on the number of people in
intensive care
ninety percent have not had their
booster and sixty percent have not had
any vaccination at all
he will know that there are people out
there with very good reasons not to be
vaccinated
and they get tarred with the same brush
as people who have been reading nonsense
on the internet can we have better stats
so that people can see the benefits of
vaccination and be encouraged to take it
up because obviously everybody benefits
if they are not in hospital
whatever um
it's a very powerful and important point
because uh we should not bully or or
demonize those who simply cannot for
medical or whatever reasons uh get uh
get vaccinated and
of course that is that is right but it
is also very very important that people
understand mr speaker the benefits to
them to their families
of getting uh boosted in particular uh
the benefits are overwhelming they're
there for everybody to see and i'm
afraid that tragic statistic about uh
about people in uh icu is plain for all
to see clive betts
thank you mr speaker
the government were right to encourage
people to get tested over the holiday
period
like many of my constituents and
thousands of people across the country i
work around several pharmacies and all i
saw were notes in the window saying no
lateral flow tests available that's the
reality of the situation prime minister
so ask the prime minister two simple
questions what steps did he take before
the holiday period to get an assurance
for himself
that tests were going to be freely
available
and secondly when did he become
available aware that actually millions
of tests were locked away in a warehouse
and wouldn't be available after the
holiday period
right minister uh mr speaker we we took
every possible step to
step up our supply of of tests we
tripled the uh the supplies and uh
deliveries went up to
000 a day mr speaker and to listen to
them to listen to them you would not
believe that this was the country that
was conducting more tests up ahead than
any other country in europe uh
they simply they are simply refusing uh
to give credit where it's due i
appreciate that huge numbers of people
want to be tested but we are doing our
level best to meet demand
i very much welcome my honourable
friends announcements today one of the
best things we could do both for public
health and for our hard press hospitals
is to make sure that the the small but
significant number of people who refuse
vaccination altogether
are persuaded of the error of their ways
so can i ask him to redouble the
government's efforts some will no doubt
be completely misguidedly recalcitrant
but i believe that the vast majority are
persuadable so whether through education
or advertising or anything frankly this
side of coercion can he redouble the
government's efforts to persuade those
who are unvaccinated to take the jab
minister
he's quite right and that's why we're
enlisting the help of community leaders
up and down the country anybody uh who
who speaks with authority in in
communities to get that message across
and that's why the vaccine task force as
i recall spent 675 000 pounds on
outreach
to hard to
groups and what did the party opposite
say they said the funding couldn't be
justified yeah sammy wilson mr speaker
first of all can i give the prime
minister credit for not rushing into new
restrictions despite the historical
views of some of the medical advisors
only wish the
the health minister in northern ireland
had taken some advice from him rather
than rushing into restrictions and also
welcome the lifting of restrictions on
the aviation industry and the need for
pre-departure tests
the price the prime minister has rightly
identified that one of the problems at
present is the shortage of staff in the
national health service because of the
need to isolate
but looking forward can he tell us what
concerns he has what plans he has made
for when the
the vaccine mandate applies to health
service staff
the assessment which has been made by
the health minister will be that up to
114 000 staff will not be available
because they haven't been vaccinated or
won't have been vaccinated is he
concerned about the pressures on the
health service call me april
mr actually mr speaker well i thank you
but we are seeing uh very encouraging
signs of take up uh both in the health
sector and in social care that's a great
thing it's a positive thing uh for
individuals in in both those professions
charlotte
speaker at the start of the pandemic
there was evidence that members of the
bme community were more vulnerable to
the covid virus
has there been any analysis carried out
to determine whether or not omicron
acts in a similar way or not the prime
minister will appreciate that this is of
particular relevance given the
significant number of people from the
bame community who work in the health
and care sector
prime minister i thank uh my right
friend very much he makes an extremely
important very important question i
think i think the answer is there are
currently no evidence uh to but uh what
there certainly is uh evidence for is
that uh the different levels of vaccine
take up uh and booster take up in
particular amongst different groups are
certainly affecting outcomes mike
thanks mr speaker israeli gave his one
nation speech in manchester in 1872 i
doubt he would recognize the party
political knock about the prime
minister's engaging it over a national
crisis so what i will what i will say
prime minister about the situation is
that tonight with case rate right rates
rising in greater manchester there are
600 patients across gm who can't get out
of hospital due to social care staff
shortages around half of hair care homes
are not accepting anyone currently this
has to not do with just the pandemic
this is historic under investment in our
social care sector surely the prime
minister sees that
sorry
a couple of points uh i think he knows
much about israeli by the way uh but uh
the mayor of greater manchester uh
actually has just said that the
government is taking the right approach
and on his point about uh the uh fixing
the problems in the social care sector
which is a valid one it's this
government after decades of failure by
labor uh to do it
absolutely true
we are we are actually fixing social
care we're fixing social care and they
wouldn't even support it
[Music]
look at that
i hope you had a good christmas break i
hope you had a better break than the
shadow health secretary because since we
last met he's had a number of positions
on the 19th he said the government needs
to act now and labour called for actions
before boxing day on the 20th he said
british public know that additional
restrictions are inevitable on the 21st
he criticized the delay and then on the
27th he said people will be relieved to
hear that there are no new restrictions
we all want a responsible constructive
opposition but does the prime minister
agree with me that's not opposition
that's opportunism
[Music]
well
there you go mr speaker and it sums up
all you need to know about the the
labour party that they instinctively
reach uh for measures to lock down uh
the eur the uk economy to do huge damage
uh what we're taking is a balanced and a
proportionate approach and there are
there are there are there are
difficulties ahead but we are taking the
right approach and if they if that's if
they're now saying that they support it
are they saying they support it
are they saying
i don't know mr speaker uh let's wait
for captain hindsight to come back
deadly
the prime minister has made his position
clear that the government will see out
this current wave
without any further restrictions or any
support for businesses but he will know
of course the government of wales has
implemented new measures to limit the
spread of the virus as such would you
not agree with me that it would be
better for wales to be forded with a
fiscal powers required to support these
public health measures so that the welsh
government's response is as flexible and
as effective as possible
uh mr speaker actually the the the uk
government uh has supported wales and
the whole of the uk throughout the
pandemic uh to the tune of
billions and billions of pounds and uh
we supply the vaccines we supply the
testing kits and uh we will continue
further we will continue uh to do
everything to support the whole of the
uk good job
thank you mr speaker mr speaker on
friday i'll be holding my team meeting
in the local pub because under welsh
government rules we are not allowed to
go to our socially distanced office we
cannot do park run we cannot watch
outdoor sports on the touchline but we
can catch up together in the clubhouse
to watch it can i commend the prime
minister for his bold decisions and ask
whether he agrees that the
inconsistencies in the rules in wales
are not just ludicrous they are harming
the welsh economy
[Applause]
mr speaker i i've tried to be uh
consensual across this house i have and
and
and to build on uh to build on those
aspects of of our handling of kobit
uh our handling of well i was very
consensual to him i thought he was
brother uh frankly rather rude uh but uh
mr speaker we we there is much let me
put it this way there is much much more
uh that unites all parts of the uk in
our handling of cambridge than
absolutely than divides us uh compared
with any other uh european country we
are moving uh virtually in lockstep
there are some baroque uh
eccentricities uh in various other parts
of the in in wales uh i i make no
comment on them uh but i i repeat what
i've what i've said uh we will continue
uh to provide support throughout the uk
justin mothers
thank you mr speaker many of my
constituents who are doing the right
thing and
are finding out that they're getting
frustrated at day six and seven because
they can't access the lateral flow test
that they need to to be able to be
released early this is despite the
health secretary telling this house just
three weeks ago the country had tens of
millions of tests so can the prime
minister tell us what's gone wrong and
will you apologize to my constituents
for putting them in this position
well mr speaker i certainly share the
frustrations of everybody who's found it
difficult to get a test during a time of
unbelievable uh demand and
what we have done we have taken
responsibility by tripling uh supply
and creating our own homegrown uk
lateral flow testing manufacturing
capability of which the uh the the labor
front bench uh was in unbelievable
ignorance when this debate began
earlier this week the ligature hospitals
declared a critical incident and no
doubt people in lincolnshire thought
that they were being overwhelmed with
kobe but the lingerie mps were told
yesterday by nhs officials that of all
the intensive care beds in literature
only two were taken by people because of
or with covid and although there were
large numbers of staff absences a
quarter of them were accounted by staff
being absent because they were isolated
so the suspicion is that the nhs is not
being brought to its knees by covid but
by these rules that require people to
isolate for so long so what is the road
map for shortening the period of
isolation
uh
what we're doing uh i thank my on what
we're doing is supporting uh the nhs
supporting staff making sure that we
have as much capacity as possible
and actually absentee absence is
absenteeism although uh it's high is not
as high as it has been at some other
points in this uh in this pandemic
that's no cause for complacency what we
will do is keep the uh the period of
isolation under constant review uh if we
think we can bring it down without
increasing infection then of course we
will alex
thank you uh mr speaker um the prime
minister rightly lords our life science
industry british university british
scientists have helped us get through
covid so why then after developing the
uk vaccine manufacturing innovation
center has the government
and they said it's been developed with
taxpayer money alongside british
university the government decided to
sell it off into private hand so future
pandemics future vaccines won't be held
in public in for all of us but in a few
private hands
grateful i i think what we're doing is
investing hundreds of millions to make
sure that we have a a dynamic vaccine
industry and clearly government needs to
work hand in glove with the private
sector
as we have done no matter how deep the
abhorrence of the private sector they
may be on the opposite benches it was
private sector private capital that
produced the vaccine success
speaker at the beginning of 2020
stepping hill hospital in my
constituency was under such severe
winter pressures that it was reaching
critical opal four since then doctors
nurses and staff have worked tirelessly
during the course of this pandemic but
covet is now taking its toll uh
particularly the own prom virus and it's
one of 17 hospitals that have said that
they will not be doing any more or
taking a pause on non-urgent surgery
would my right honourable friend and the
secretary of state work with the greater
manchester hospital trust
to ensure that they get all the support
they need through this really critical
time
i thank her for i thank her for all the
support that she gives to uh to
hospitals in the greater manchester uh
area which i i know well in which where
she knows uh we're investing uh hugely
uh i thank them for the
the care and the trouble that they're
taking in a very very tough time they'll
get all the support that they need very
brief ones christine
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
has to make decisions based on evidence
however currently reinfections are not
included in the uk government code cases
figures and that's despite warnings by
scientists at imperial college london up
to 15
of omicron cases could be of people who
have had coronavirus before so can the
prime minister assure us that the
infections will be tracked and recorded
in the uk government's dashboard and if
so when
yeah yeah
i'm grateful tim but the the uh decision
is up to the uk health security agency
thank you very much uh mr speaking can i
welcome the ongoing support financial
and otherwise for our hospitality sector
uh particularly those where it is a
critical lifeline even still of course
the best thing we can do for them is to
take away all restrictions that remain
in place but we also have to recognize
there may be an opposite scenario where
new restrictions are considered in the
future to that end can my right
honourable friend confirm that weddings
and funerals would be exempt from any
further restrictions in the future
well there are no restrictions on them
at the moment mr speaker that's
certainly the way we wish to keep it
matt weston
thank you mr speaker
um
the
in warwickshire there were 436 excess
deaths uh due to covert last year
currently 77 in care homes 77
of
residents and staffing codes are
currently boosted
the other
23 aren't what is the government doing
to ensure that they do get the boost of
vaccination so we don't repeat the
mistakes of last year
often the problem in care homes is that
is that somebody they may have they may
have had kobe recently and therefore
aren't eligible for the booster so
people have to come around but we're
doing that as fast as we possibly can dr
luke evans
thank you mr speaker and it was welcomed
by both sides of their house when in the
summer the prime minister came to the
dispatch box to announce an inquiry was
going to take place on the lessons
learned and just before we broke for
parliament it was announced that
baroness hallett would be leading this
inquiry can the prime minister give us
an update on how the panel's forming the
timings of when this will happen and the
terms of reference as they should appear
i thank him under the inquiries act as
the house knows it's up to the uh the
chair of the inquiry to uh begin framing
the terms of reference herself
thank you mr speaker like members across
the house many pharmacies in my
constituency are out of stock of lateral
flow tests and when you try to order
online it says that none are available
yet the sunday times reported this week
that british manufacturers of lateral
flow tests are battling with the
government after
their kits failed to be cleared for use
in this country despite being available
in europe so when will the prime
minister pull his finger out to boost
testing capacity and boost british
manufacturing
[Applause]
yeah sorry
mr speaker the uh of course kits need to
be approved uh by the uh perhaps he
wants uh kits that aren't approved uh to
be on the market and they have to be
approved by the the mhra and the and
that's the right thing uh but actually
but my understanding is that we've been
up at 15 percent of uh of lateral
lateral flow tests in this country being
supplied uh in the uk from zero
mr speaker i um congratulate the prime
minister for sticking to his guns and
not bringing in additional restrictions
over a festive period and charging
threatening to charge up to 60 pounds
for going to work like we did in wales
however the mental health damage done by
even the threat and the fear of
restrictions has been significant some
of my conversations have actually said
it was worse this time than it was
actually when lockdown happened because
then they thought it was a light at the
end of a tunnel and their fear now is
that this could be a never-ending
nightmare could the prime minister give
me assurances that mental health is at
the heart of the decision until they can
feature on clovid
uh he makes uh an incredibly powerful
point which i think should be heard uh
on all sides of the house to calling for
uh for restrictions as as the right
honourable gentleman opposite i think
who i think speaks for health uh on
health uh matters uh repeatedly before
uh christmas uh these have these have an
effect on people uh lockdowns have an
effect on people and particularly on
mental health so tony lloyd
thank you mr speaker can would the
premise make it very clear to some of
these backbenchers that
a strategy for living with cove it can't
include every hospital in greater
manchester not being able to deliver
elective surgery as
other honourable members are already
raised but will he make it absolutely
clear that there is a strategy that
would make sure that people for example
like one of my close friends who needs a
hip replacement because she's in such
pain that there will be retrospectively
the resources put in to make sure that
we catch up in greater manchester
yes and that that's why we have the uh
nhs and social care fund uh that's why
uh we're putting that measure through uh
how unbelievable that you guys didn't
vote for him mr speaker not you
holy mamby croft
mr speaker um i was fortunate to visit
our local new vaccination hub in
skunkthorpe and speak to the healthcare
professionals and staff who are doing a
tremendous job of not just jabbing
people very efficiently in the arm but
reassuring those residents who are still
a bit nervous it's a small number of
residents about joining the rest of us
uh in having their vaccination so will
my befriend the prime minister thank
those wonderful volunteers and staff
across my school thought constituency
for the important work they're doing and
their contribution to this national
effort that he is leading yeah
i i i share her uh sentiments entirely
mr speaker i thank the nhs staff and i
thank all the our incredible volunteers
many thanks mr speaker as chair of the
health all-party parliamentary group
i've been contacted by people up and
down the united kingdom who tell me
they're still having great difficulty in
accessing gp appointments gps are
working absolutely flat out during this
pandemic however there do appear to be
ongoing capacity issues so what more can
be done to support gps to increase the
capacity that's needed because
other illnesses are ongoing throughout
this pandemic that must be seen at an
early stage and ensure that everyone who
needs to see a gp is able to do so
timelessly and safely
i agree with her completely about gps
they've been particular heroes of the
the vaccine rollout and uh what we're
doing we've got 1300 more gps this year
than last year we need to do more that's
why we put another 250 million pounds
into our supporting gps right now ben
spent
mr speaker and i thank my right
honourable friend for holding firm on
plan b
and for rolling back on the travel
restrictions which will relieve many of
my constituents can i also welcome the
increased use of blatant flow testing
for diagnostic testing but could i ask
him to clarify is it therefore the case
at the moment this will only be for
asymptomatic testing so for people who
don't have symptoms if people do have
symptoms they'll still be required to
get a pcr test and if so can i urge them
to to look into further using lateral
flow tests for that because until when
people have symptoms they don't have to
trundle over to a pcr testing center
wait 24 hours to get results and self
isolate until back negative we will
still not be living with the virus
that's right mr speaker we will we'll be
encouraging people uh to to do so but it
won't be compulsory
mccarthy
thank you mr speaker in response to the
honourable member for sheffield south
east earlier when he talked about the
severe shortages of lateral protests in
pharmacies the prime minister was
incredibly dismissive he seemed to be
suggesting he was making it all up he
might like to speak to my constituent
who both phoned and emailed me on monday
desperate to go to work the next day as
a crucial frontline nhs worker just
couldn't get his hands on a test at all
i ended up popping around there myself
because i had some spare tests can he
assure me that from now on my
constituent will be able to get the
tests that he needs when he needs them
so that he can go to work and do his job
[Applause]
mrs because she really mustn't
misrepresent uh what i said i began by
saying that i shared the frustrations of
people up and down the country uh who
have been unable uh to get uh the tests
that they wanted i also pointed out uh
that uh we had a huge a huge demand uh
for tests that we were doing our level
best to meet that we tripled uh supply
uh that we were making them in this in
this country on a scale never seen uh
before and uh that we're doing more
testing than any other country uh in in
europe and we and and that is those
those are positives but i i fully accept
that it's been uh difficult for people
uh to get tests and uh but we are
stepping up supply the whole time yeah
please do thank you mr speaker
representing a constituency with a very
international outlook i warmly welcome
the changes to the travel regulations
my constituency is also very dependent
upon commuters coming into central
london certain businesses are suffering
with the work from home guidance
can my right honorable friend assure me
that we will drop the work from home
guidance at the earliest possible
opportunity
uh we will do so mr speaker whenever uh
it is safe but the measures that you
know uh that as she knows expire in any
event on uh january the 26th
thank you mr speaker parents of children
who are primary school age with
disabilities will have been disappointed
not to hear about the roll out of the
vaccine for five to 11 year olds within
the statement two puppy parents have
written to me this week one with a child
with cystic fibrosis and one with down
syndrome so they've been shielding since
march 2020 they're desperate to to leave
shielding they really want the vaccine
they can't get it um could the prime
minister say more about when the vaccine
would be rolled out for
children who are vulnerable who are five
to eleven
yes we've accepted the advice of the
jcdi uh for at-risk uh five to
eleven-year-olds and we'll be rolling it
out later this month
thank you mr speaker i welcome the
announcement of no new restrictions and
the changes to testing for travel which
makes it far easier and cheaper for
families to go abroad but many
immuno-suppressed people in record
cleveland are unsure about what they
should be doing in the face of omicron
can the prime minister give a message to
those who were previously shielding
the i'm grateful to my own friend he's
raised the the issues of the
immunosuppressed before and i and i
understand uh the points he makes we've
contacted 1.3 million of them mr speaker
with a view to
giving them treatment with antivirals
thank you mr speaker
his answers about the shortage of tests
would have more credibility if he were
to support british manufacturing when my
honourable friend from lewiston west
asked him before about why it is that
british manufacturers have not been
given
permission to make uh lateral protests
and sell them in this country but they
have in the european union
why is it that the european union has
given them permission that the uk
government hasn't would he perhaps find
out the answer to that because this will
all this will both increase the supply
of tests which are in chronic short
supply as we've heard again and again
this afternoon and it is a great way of
supporting the british economy and
manufacturing in this country
mr speaker i'm afraid he's talking total
nonsense because uh the the there was no
manufacturing capability at all in this
country uh for lateral flow tests and uh
we now have a the largest single
manufacturing plant in europe let me
repeat that because i don't think they
knew this the largest single
manufacturing plant for lfd tests in
europe in the uk
and
of course it's also important mr speaker
we are using them uh it's also important
that other manufacturers or
manufacturers who want to supply lateral
flow tests should pass the mhra's uh
test and i think that that's what the
public would expect
for the digitally excluded the need to
go online to obtain a code to take to
the pharmacy to obtain your lateral flow
tests has proven a real barrier can the
prime minister say what assessment the
government has made of the extent of
this problem and how it will be
addressed
i i think she's very raising a very
important point uh we try to make sure
that uh we help people uh by delivering
tests and um many many pharmacies of
course are more than happy to to to do
it without an online booking
thank you very much mr speaker last
summer the respected senior journalist
paul wall reported that the prime
minister was accused of making empty
promises to the british bio-science
firms after it emerged that rapid covert
tests offered to nhs staff were
manufactured by a chinese firm so is the
nhs now buying british or were the prime
minister's words today about british
manufacturing simply more hot air yeah
i really really don't think that the
opposition front venture
or indeed any of them they haven't got
the faintest idea what's going on uh mr
speaker they haven't got the faintest
idea they have six or seven uh different
positions about lockdown
and and they simply you know they came
into this uh this statement this
afternoon not even knowing that this
country has the largest lateral flow
manufacturing facility in europe they
didn't know it
is cool
thank you mr speaker
in the statement the um the prime
minister indicated
that
in his statement the prime minister
indicated that lateral flow tests would
be given to a hundred thousand critical
workers but the national railways alone
employ almost double that number and gps
and pharmacists in my constituency of st
albans are wondering why they have not
been included as critical workers as
well indeed we could add supermarket
workers to that list so could the prime
minister please explain where that
number of a hundred thousand came from
because it seems at the moment it was
plucked out of the air for yesterday's
press conference
she's i i i understand the point that
she uh she makes and i know that a lot
of people have jumped to the same
conclusion that that she has about or
what we could do we've targeted the 100
000 uh that we have in mind i mean
obviously all the uh the public sector
has access to free tests including
teachers and and everybody else but what
we wanted to do particularly uh was to
ensure that those those vital nodes like
uh railway uh uh signaling uh hubs uh
other crucial like hgvs uh that they had
access to tests
i'd like to also thank the prime
minister for helping praise on the
amazing team at redbridge town hall led
by dr c dat in milford south who managed
on christmas day and boxing day to
vaccinate seventeen hundred people a
phenomenal effort but yet mr speaker at
the same time we hear that nhs workers
across their country and their thousands
are not at work because i can't get the
tests that they need so mr speaker i
would like to ask the prime minister
when is he going to sort it out when is
he going to prioritize having nhs and
other frontline staff like in transport
actually getting those tests prioritized
mr speaker he needs to get a grip he
needs to get a grip fast
i'm afraid that he's not right
because the nhs staff
there are many reasons for nhs staff
sadly being absent but a shortage of
their inability to get testing kits is
not one of them they have access to the
nhs supply but also to community
supplies as well rachel maskel
thank you mr speaker letting kofi drip
through our communities has come at such
serious cost placing new burdens on
business putting more risk on our health
and care system and also an unnecessary
cost to lives in york the infection
rates are on a part with london apart
from they are still rising sharply
can the prime minister explain not only
why tests are being rationed but also
why there is a doubling of the contact
tracing time which is released to our
local authorities delaying that vital
opportunity to lock down the virus
quickly
sorry mr speaker i know that the
honourable lady opposite is pro lock
down i don't think that's the right way
forward we're taking a balanced and a
proportional approach and that's what
this country's going to do
last but certainly not least and happy
new year to jim shy
[Applause]
the strongest legends chamber i've been
bobbing from that for the last hour and
a half you know
can i thank the prime minister very much
for his statement and for his reply will
the prime minister outline if he intends
to work with the chancellor and the
treasurer treasury to provide a scheme
for small businesses who employ under
five people
and they are allowing to close with no
income when there's a very contagious
ombre con code case or a close contact
too many businesses prime minister which
are viable and successful can no longer
hang on be a threat and need a further
package for help right now thank you
mr speaker as he knows we've given uh
very significant support to businesses
uh throughout the pandemic we keep it
under review but uh what would not be
good for businesses would be to release
people back into the workplace too soon
so that they in uh everybody else there
is it relevant to this
disappointed that the prime minister has
left the chamber because i did inform
him that i would be making a point of
order at the end of his statement mr
speaker during the
statement the prime minister twice asked
me to withdraw
the remarks that i had made in the
statement i do not withdraw any of the
remarks i made in the statement because
i'm happy to confirm that everything
that we have said was truthful and was
about making sure that the prime
minister was addressing the comments
that we were putting and that is in
sharp contrast